foreign
[Music]
it's time for some updates on your
favorite movies and series while Barbie
continues to dominate the global box
office filming on Sonic 3 is getting
started under very special circumstances
Deadpool fans in particular need to
brace themselves this time as there's
news about the scheduled theatrical
release this and much more awaits you in
the latest kenocheck news
what's your favorite scary movie
Ghostface will ask his victims this
question again in part 7 of the
successful horror movie series this time
the director is Christopher Landon who
should be a familiar name to fans of the
genre Scream 5 and scream 6 not only
thrilled fans of the franchise but also
proved to be extremely successful for
Paramount Pictures it should therefore
hardly come as a surprise that part 7
has been officially confirmed still
there will be some changes compared to
the predecessors the duo Matt vetinelli
and Tyler Gillette are no longer in
charge of directing as they were for
parts 5 and 6. however they will still
be involved in the project as executive
producers the two explain their exit
with the fact that they prefer to devote
themselves to a more original horror
flight which is also to be released
under Paramount there is no reason to be
sad though because as already mentioned
Christopher Landon will take over the
directing duties for scream 7. the
director should definitely be a
household name for those from familiar
with the genre and has already proven
with the happy death Day movie series
and his body swap Thriller freaky that
he has a feeling for horror and comedy
and takes no prisoners in terms of
brutality nothing is known about the
story of Scream 7 yet it also remains
unclear whether Jenna Ortega Melissa
Barrera and Mason Gooding will be
returning it was reported that the
actors have not been signed for the
sequel yet however we may assume that
they will be back in part 7 as well
after all they have been an integral
part of the franchise since scream 5. we
are looking forward to the return of
Ghostface and we'll keep you posted as
soon as there's more information about
the iconic serial killer
there is hope the science fiction film
Edge of Tomorrow starring Tom Cruise and
Emily Blunt enjoyed great popularity a
possible sequel was long under
discussion but there was never any
concrete information now Emily Blunt has
spoken out for the first time about the
rumors of a sequel it's been almost 10
years since the science fiction genre
had their fun with Edge of Tomorrow the
film fell back on the popular Groundhog
Day concept and put it into the guise of
a rousing action thriller given the
positive response from fans and critics
they did consider a sequel which however
came to nothing in the following years
now though there seems to be some
activity regarding the project Edge of
Tomorrow Too lead actress Emily Blunt
revealed on the happy sad confused
podcast that she had actually read the
script she said that Doug Lyman director
and co-writer of part one had given it
to her personally she thought a film
adaptation would be great but the only
question was when and how above all it
would depend on how many more Mission
Impossible movies her Coast star Tom
Cruise wanted to make she was convinced
that the world would also like to see
more of Tom Cruise in Edge of Tomorrow
it would certainly not fail because of
her I'm so ready the British actress
assured
a shock for all Deadpool fans the big
mouth mercenary was supposed to make his
comeback in May together with Wolverine
nothing will become of it however for
the time being the actors and writers
strike for better working conditions is
currently shutting down all of Hollywood
and causing chaos at the studios the
sequel Deadpool 3 was only recently
brought forward to May 3rd 2024 to the
fans Delight of course however the
enthusiasm is now likely to be dampened
Disney recently revealed their annual
overview of upcoming movies for the
period between September 2023 and June
2024 and it was not long before it
became apparent that the apparent
release date for Deadpool 3 has
surprisingly been canceled without
replacement the plan of upcoming
projects in the MCU was regularly upset
by Disney in recent months there have
been recurring problems with the
production of the new blade film for
example which was also originally
supposed to be released in 2024 as a
result several projects had to be
postponed since the MCU movies are known
to be based on each other the current
wave of postponement on the other hand
is due to the current actors in writer
strike the shooting of Deadpool 3 was
already suspended in July which meant
that the planned release in May of next
year was doubtful anyway now though it
seems that the date really cannot be met
Deadpool 3 is now likely to set a new
record for postponement schedules in the
MCU with the announcement of Hugh
Jackman's return the movie was
originally slated to Premiere in
September 2024. after that the movie was
pushed back by two months to November
and then moved up again to May 3rd what
a mess it remains to be seen when we
will finally get to see the spectacular
Deadpool and Wolverine but the
developments of the strike will continue
to impact possible release dates of the
movie
Sonic returns filming is officially
scheduled to begin this September on
part three of the popular video game
adaptation regardless of the actor
strike the solution to the problem is
surprisingly simple it's understandable
that they didn't want to wait any longer
to produce Sonic 3. for Paramount
Pictures the previous movie adaptations
of the iconic Hedgehog proved to be
extremely successful Sonic 1 and Sonic 2
collectively grossed over 700 billion
dollars worldwide it was therefore
unsurprising that in addition to the
planned spin-off series Knuckles a third
part of the film series was also
announced however when the actor strike
came into effect on July 14 2023 all
movie and TV Productions were put on
hold for an unknown period of time
including Sonic 3. nevertheless screen
Daily Now reports that they have
apparently found a way to carry out the
filming despite the ongoing strike it
was announced that the production team
for Sonic 3 will start shooting in
September of this year without the
actor's involvement the filming location
in London proves to be extremely
beneficial for the production as there
as there are no picketing guidelines in
the UK that could prevent a production
from taking place without the actors
Sonic and his companions are CGI
characters anyway in the Shadow the
Hedgehog character also originates from
the computer so it should be an easy
task to devote some of the production to
them first the actor scenes would then
be added after the strike is over
however it is already suspected that
they will play a rather minor role in
the third part anyway fans are likely to
be relieved that the planned release
date of December 20th 2024 remains
unchanged for the strikers on the other
hand this news puts a damper on the
situation because any production that
continues despite the strike is likely
to considerably reduce the pressure on
the opposing side still the full
production of Sonic the Hedgehog 3 can
only be concluded after the strike is
over in the end things can't be done
without the actors
unbelievable the Barbie movie about the
famous plastic doll has already achieved
a phenomenal success at the global box
office after only 17 days and is
currently the second most successful
movie of the year it's a unique success
story Barbie has been in theaters for a
mere three weeks and it already stands a
good chance of becoming the most watched
movie of the year the story of Barbie
and Ken recently surpassed the billion
dollar Mark with its box office takings
making it a hit that surely no one would
have anticipated when a Barbie movie
adaptation was first announced the
reasons for this huge success are
probably many and very on the one hand
it is an absolute favorite among critics
and viewers scoring 89 on Rotten
Tomatoes and a critics average of 80 on
Metascore on the other hand the success
is probably also thanks to the superb
marketing campaign anyone who is
regularly on social media is unlikely to
have missed the hashtag larbenheimer
during the shooting of the film photos
from the set were also published over
and over again showing Margot Robbie and
Ryan Gosling in brightly colored outfits
hanging out in Venice Beach for example
this led to a number of collaborations
with Brands such as Airbnb Google Crocs
and Tick Tock if one combines these
versatile aspects with one another and
includes the word of mouth advertising
Factor the result became a campaign that
was almost impossible to resist but the
success includes another special aspect
Greta Gerwig goes down in Hollywood
history as the most successful female
director of all time thus displacing the
previous title holder and Wonder Woman
director Patty Jenkins meanwhile the
other part of the barberheimer
phenomenon Christopher Nolan's
Oppenheimer has to be content with a box
office result of currently 560 million
dollars that surely is an impressive
figure too but the winner of the box
office duel between the two unequal
films should be clear the challenge now
is to knock the Super Mario Brothers
movie off its title as the most
successful film of the year the animated
film about the famous plumber was able
to bring in more than 1.3 billion
dollars worldwide and is thereby
relatively close to barbecue so it may
only be a matter of time before more
records are broken
now that you're up to date with
Hollywood and the like are there any
other bits of news that you'd like to
share with the community go ahead and
post them in the comments and if you
enjoy our news videos feel free to leave
a like should you not have had enough
content yet well this week we also have
a nice preview of John Wick's ballerina
on our channel so feel free to check it
out see you next time
[Music]
thank you